it is a difficult life in the sense that
she Dina was born a boy and knew already
in in the early stages of her life that
she was born with the wrong body
you
the mindset of hers is to make the best
out of the situation and not give up and
that's where I also come in in regards
to my interest in such stories I adore
admire and love people that have dealt
with struggles in their lives or are
still dealing with it but with a certain
kind of loudness the struggles are
everywhere compensate she's surrounded
by friends and family that supporter and
that protector they do a laugh together
and they do also get maybe harass
together but at the same time they are
strong together that keeps them stronger
I think all in all South Africa even
though they are still many obstacles to
overcome it's still on the front run of
being a beautiful example of positive
future for the LGBT community as I said
there's still a long way to go but as
with people as she Dino in the front
feeling very very good about it
you